[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists enjoy
hey guys i'm arturo nice to meet you
brother what's on your mind
so i wanted to ask now that you are not
trying to bite things to be happier what
are your thoughts on
happiness got something pithy for it
even i went ooh
i'll tell you my thoughts on happiness
i'll start with some pithy and maybe we
can unpack it
your happiness is moderated by your
expectations
and the reason we're so miserable we're
so upset all the time is because
everyone upsets us right
it's all relational almost always right
so here's something else pithy for you
every person
that you interact with will make you
miserable
um
don't go tweeting that one
it's just a fundamental truth but
there's a truth behind that truth
it's not them that's making
us miserable making me miserable making
you miserable it's our expectations
about those people
if i expect the reason ryan's in my
relationship works so well and has for
30 years although there's there have
been bumpy times but it's always been
bumpy because one of us had a crappy
expectation of the other person
and of course
an expectation is a is a type of
clinging
it's hoping something's going to be
different in some
hypothetical non-existent future and if
i cling to that hope that expectation
i'm gonna get dragged by it yeah oh
happiness is it's i
i was like a really young kid
and i just remember seeing in different
tv programs or even like in cartoons
there was always this like what's the
answer to life like i remember like some
bugs bunny cartoon and like the guy's
climbing to the mountain and he gets to
the yo like what's the answer answer to
life and he throws a pie in his face or
something but
but i was like asking this question as a
kid and i was like oh the point of life
is to be happy and if you look at our
constitution like it's it's written in
the constitution the pursuit of
happiness
and so that's that is what life was to
me pursuing happiness
and i would argue that in the corporate
world
every once in a while i would like i'd
get that raise or that promotion
and i would like have happiness and like
as soon as i grabbed it though it would
like slip out of my hand
and i just kept chasing grabbing
slipping grabbing slipping and i had
this constant
chase going on
and what i've realized is now for me the
point is not happiness the point is uh
it's living a meaningful life and what
that means is that your actions are well
for for me it means that my actions are
in alignment with my values that's when
i can look in the mirror and if i even
if i'm not having a good day i could be
like well dude you tried your best today
you know like you at least like did what
you you felt was right so if i was to
give you a pithy answer i would say
uh happiness is ephemeral
meaningful work lasts forever
wow
i think the nice thing about that too is
happiness is then a byproduct of living
a meaningful life and so it's not the
chase it's not the pursuit happiness
can't be pursued it can only be
uncovered as we talked about earlier
but you can uncover it by doing that
which you find to be meaningful
thank you guys thanks brother
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit
the
patreon.com
today your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel one hundred percent
advertisement free